let's say hypothetically that i made
some bad financial bets
maybe i was irresponsible with a credit
card maybe i got involved in a
certain shaped scheme i've got a lot of
debt
and i gotta get out of it well companies
go bankrupt all the time
can i do that
so i've got no way to pay off this debt
creditors are hounding me
and the stress is just building and
building i've got to go find a lawyer
specifically a bankruptcy lawyer my name
is steven starr
i'm an attorney here in new york i
practice bankruptcy and restructuring
with a law firm star and star plc when
should a person
consider personal bankruptcy so that's a
good question i mean as a bankruptcy
attorney
you know we're not trying to push or
sell bankruptcy we're always looking at
what's the best
solution for an individual the the first
question
is what are your debts which is a total
of how much money do you owe
in terms of things like credit cards or
back rent or
student loans and then what's your
income what's the money that's coming in
and we compare those and if you have you
know more money coming in
than you owe and it's not too burdensome
you know it's somewhere below
let's say 50 percent which you know a
lot of people in new york pay really
high rent
maybe people can get out of it through
budgeting right i'm a big fan of
budgeting but if you're in a really deep
hole budgeting is not going to help
sure a lot of my clients it's it's
literally their debt is a multiple
of their income so they owe a hundred
thousand they earn
50 and that's you know gross numbers
before taxes the other thing is
people are about to start the next
chapter of their life and what do i mean
by that someone was an entrepreneur
they had a business it didn't work out
um
and now they're going to do something
else well should they
keep paying back all the debt that they
incurred in the failed business or
should they work
on the next chapter like so if a person
is considering it
um what should their first step be is
that to reach out to an attorney
i don't view bankruptcy as a first
resort i do view it as a last resort so
i think the first step
and you you might be surprised here this
people need to get control of just
understanding the numbers
some sometimes you know clients come in
and they'll have all these envelopes in
a bag
and they don't they're not opening their
mail because they're dealing from fear
literally making piles and and figuring
out you know how much do you owe and
adding that up and looking at your
expenses
so could you explain to me the
difference between chapter 7 and chapter
13.
chapter 13 is really useful for people
who need the chance to catch up with
payments over time
we would usually use that if someone has
a if they own a home and they're facing
a foreclosure or they've fallen behind
on their payments
it's going to be a really helpful tool i
think for people bouncing back
after all these covid troubles and if
people lost their jobs but then found a
new job
they can then catch up over as much as
five years through a chapter 13 plan
[Music]
it's like a repayment plan it's a court
enforced repayment plan
in in a chapter seven what assets do you
get to keep
and and what gets taken away seven is uh
liquidation and the idea there is you're
filing a bankruptcy case
most people's debt again going back to
sort of like broad examples
98 99 of my clients debts
you know do get wiped out with the
exception of like student loans
and certain tax debts
most individuals most of my clients when
they file chapter seven
um they get to keep all their property
but the way chapter seven works there's
a person called the bankruptcy trustee
so an example i often use is if someone
had a collection of luxury cars porsche
lamborghini maserati ferrari
very high-end luxury automobiles the law
is not going to let you keep
automobiles with that level of value
it's going to give you some
money back but the trustee would hire an
auctioneer
have an auction get bankruptcy court
permission do that take that money
pay the creditors for both chapter 7 or
13
maybe maybe the answer is different what
is the long-term impact on your
financial health
there's something called the fair credit
reporting act which governs
credit reporting and that says that the
credit granters can look to bankruptcy
up to 10 years
but the the sort of um received wisdom
is
if you file um you know if you file
a a seven you're going to rebuild your
credit in a
much faster time than that and at the
end of the process
you know most of my clients are able to
rebuild their credit within a few years
there is life after bankruptcy right
like they don't want to
leave people uh you know penniless and
homeless
as a result of bankruptcy it's starting
to sound like personal bankruptcy might
be for me
but it would really help if i could talk
to somebody who's been through this
process
personally i've been through bankruptcy
and i can tell you all about it henry
oh wow really uh who are you ah my name
is donald ash
and uh yes i'm a teacher that had to
file bankruptcy
probably about a decade ago tell me your
story why did you have to file in the
first place
i got into a a into a bit of a business
scam
that ended up stacking up so much debt
on me that i couldn't pay it off
so because i was a teacher not making
much money
i kind of got into a business deal that
i didn't research very well
friend recommended it and uh once i
once everything was said and done i
think i had racked up almost
almost a hundred thousand dollars in
debt how did how did you decide to
to file how did you find out like this
is the best option for me
i actually just kind of started calling
around to see what lawyers can help me
and after getting turned away from a
couple
one recommended me to a lawyer and we
got to sit down and kind of go through
just just everything that was going on
with my finances to figure out what i
could discharge and what i couldn't
beyond just the the thing that happened
with this
the business scam it also gets rid of
so that was like so that's auto loans i
think i had a credit card for like a
thousand
dollars a discover card um and
i might have had like a little bit of
like medical money to pay back but
it wasn't a lot but that also got
discharged so
at first i was just thinking maybe i
just should kind of just put the the
business stuff on there and worry about
that
but in the end i put on everything
that i could put on there and i just
said it's fine if we're going to do this
just get rid of all just everything
that's not student loans so i just have
one thing to focus on
how was this process for you i guess
mentally and emotionally while it was
going on
and you know even now i suppose i have
to say it's probably one of
the hardest things i've ever done it's
like repo man repossession people going
to your mom's house
at like the wee hours of the morning and
she doesn't know what's going on and i'm
like that
that's not what this was supposed to be
so it's just
it's just uh it was a big mess it was a
really big financial mess
one thing i can say is if you if you do
file know that
if you you can turn things around it's
it's not impossible that you have to
kind of keep in mind that things have to
change for you financially you have to
make some changes
to make sure that change can happen it
is an option and
and i'm proof that you can that you can
file bankruptcy and get through it
and come out on the other side because
yeah my credit like it's
it's in the high 700s right now so it's
back to you know a workable
yeah that's fantastic at its lowest
point it was in the low 500s like it was
even high 400s it was a god time
but you can get through it if you set a
plan for yourself with the economic
calamity caused by the pandemic you'd
expect bankruptcies to be through the
roof but that's
actually not the case i'm going to talk
to jack pitcher about it
he is right over there in the bloomberg
building
yeah my name is jack pitcher i am a
reporter on the personal finance and
wealth teams
you're not seeing a lot of bankruptcy
declarations across the country right
now
we've actually seen a decrease in
personal bankruptcies
what are the reasons for that do you
think so it's pretty much coming down to
all of the measures that have been acted
to help people
the stimulus payments the moratorium on
evictions and foreclosures
auto lenders and credit card lenders
have been more lenient
with people who are late on payments
than they typically are so
that start preventing a lot of the
events that typically
actually push people into bankruptcy um
usually when
someone an individual is filing for
bankruptcy it's because
all of a sudden their car is being
repossessed and they can't drive to work
or their home is being foreclosed on
those events that typically actually
push someone to go talk to a lawyer and
ask if they need to file
there's been less of that since the
pandemic began there there are
weirdly resilient careers that um
thrive during times like this like repo
men
and bankruptcy protection lawyers so
like
those people aren't yet seeing like a
boom in business
correct i've actually i talked to a
number of bankruptcy lawyers reporting
on this story and a lot of them
told me they're having one of their
quieter years ever
most of them are expecting a big pickup
but for the most part that hasn't
started yet
yeah is there a sense on when that might
happen i've heard a lot of people say a
lot of different things
everyone seems to agree that a wave is
coming with the level of unemployment we
saw in march and april
not very many people have a great idea
of when it will likely have to do
when some of these protections stop and
next year when we see the foreclosure
moratorium
and and some of these other things
uh there are a couple of things that
have already ended that
maybe could lead to a pickup in the
fourth quarter of this year like the
enhanced unemployment benefits it's been
a long time since there was a stimulus
payment so
there likely are going to be more people
who are cash stressed
the rest of the year than there have
been so far maybe we're looking at a
ticking time bomb waiting to go off if
you're considering personal bankruptcy
you're not alone
you